when Neil Armstrong became the first man
to walk on the moon it realized the
dream of a new frontier what Apollo 11
started in 1969 was to end three and a
half years later Apollo 17 was the final
mission to the moon and Harrison Schmitt
the 12th and last man to step out onto
the lunar surface
well my memories are largely getting to
see something that I had studied for a
very long time globe out in in space
Harrison Schmitt is the only scientist
ever to visit the moon he and captain
Eugene Cernan bringing us surely one of
the most joyful moon moments he also
captured that image of home it was
extremely important to begin to think
even further than I had before of what
our endeavors on the moon were going to
mean to understanding that earth its
history in the history of life this was
the longest lunes stay with some
remarkable discoveries worthy of
excitement the orange soil evidence of
volcanic eruptions the astronauts were
the tip of the sphere but that sphere
was held by an awful lot of people I'm a
great admirer of Neil Armstrong Neil was
in my opinion the perfect person it was
in the astronaut corps to be the first
man to step on the moon he
intellectually very strong he was a
great observer
the landing on the moon by Apollo 11 was
extremely significant to the to America
and I think to the free world because it
was in the middle of the then cold war a
competition between freedom and tyranny
basically and it added a great deal to
the psychological impact of what freedom
can due to the in the rest of the world
but since he left no one has been back I
would not have predicted that it would
be fifty years before we returned to the
moon I think it's unfortunate that
decision was made early on to shut that
a production line down a mission or two
in the deep space through the years
would have been I think very important
to humanity America's current plan is to
send a man and woman to the moon by 2024
with the ultimate aim of reaching Mars
oh I think it's definitely possible I
have great confidence in the imagination
and in capabilities of Engineers to
figure that out
but it's not going to be easy and it's
it's something that having a sustainable
presence on the moon is will be very
important as a foundation for getting to
Mars for learning how to work there well
this is a statue in honor of Apollo 17
and a geologist on the moon you see the
hammer there the first year the first
scientist the only one so far his
journey is the stuff of legend now fit
to be honored in bronze and America's
psyche he says needs success in space
returning to the moon I think will be a
very important unifying force within the
country and within the world he is one
of just four men still living to have
been the piece of moon rock he brought
back is now on display here in his home
state a priceless souvenir of his and
humanity's journey of discovery
Greg Milam Sky News New Mexico